rassemblement à julian assange est
organisée aujourd'hui à bruxelles une
journée dédiée à la liberté d'expression
et d'information et donc de soutien aux
lanceurs d'alert actuellement emprisonné
à londres julian assange qui on le
rappelle avait en 2010 révélée via
wikileaks de nombreux documents mettant
en cause l armée américaine et on en
parle tout de suite avec notre envoyé
spécial à bruxelles estelle fâchent
estelle bonjour alors comment va se
dérouler cette journée est bien samantha
c'est une journée organisée en deux
temps tout d'abord en ce moment même se
déroule ici au palais des académies de
bruxelles une cérémonie à l'initiative
de à carter académique à une
organisation qui regroupe de nombreuses
universités engagées des titres
honorifiques vont être remis à bien sûr
à julian assange mais aussi sarah
harrison chelsea manning ou encore
edouard snowden alors derrière le
pupitre de nombreux intervenants se
succèdent comme par exemple le patron de
mediapart edwy plenel ou encore le
directeur de l'information de la rtbf
la radio et télévision belge francophone
et puis dans un second temps en début
d'après-midi à la change d'aile comment
le nomme ici se poursuivra place de la
monnaie rebaptisée place à julian h en
assange pour l'occasion est là bas une
oeuvre de l'artiste david et dormino
sera inauguré il s'agit en fait de
statue de bronze représentant les trois
lanceurs d'alertés julian assange
chelsea manning et edward snowdon à ses
statuts elles resteront exposées dans la
capitale belge pendant trois jours et
puis tout au long de l'après midi des
prises
de parole et des performances
artistiques seront organisées voilà
comment on devrait se dérouler cette
journée de soutien à julian assange qui
intervient un mois avant le début du
procès à londres de julian assange
assange qui on le rappelle risque
l'extradition vers les états unis et 175
ans de prison west el farj pour toutes
ces précisions en direct de bruxelles